de la session de l'assemblée générale
annuelle
je tiens à saluer tous les pays de
l'organisation des nations unies
salué les peuples
salué les gouvernements des 194 pays
du mans présents
lors de cette assemblée générale
je salue tout particulièrement monsieur
abdulla shahid
président de l'assemblée générale je
vous souhaite un plein succès
l'assemblée annuelle de l'organisation
des nations unies
est une
manifestation qui rassemble chaque mois
de septembre chaque année
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement les
présidents
les premiers ministres et les plus
hautes autorités du monde
nous débattons de nos positions
nous débattons
d'idées
qui nous mèneront vers un monde
multipolaire
aps le riz centric sens et j'ai
hégémonisme
impérial nous nous retrouvons
pour la deuxième fois
pendant la pandémie de kobe de 19
nous nous retrouvons au sein de
l'assemblée générale nous partageons cet
espace en participant depuis nos pays
depuis les gouvernements officiel de nos
pays depuis la salle de l'assemblée
générale au siège des nations unies à
new york je salue tous les ambassadeurs
tout les ambassadrices toutes les hautes
autorités
et qui
malgré la panne et mais la pandémie
partagent leurs positions depuis leur
pays et depuis new york
elles partagent leurs
positions sur ce que doit signifier pour
l'humanité en ce 21ème siècle
la consolidation d'un nouveau monde de
paix d'un nouveau monde de coopération
d'un nouveau monde de
dialogue dans la diversité idéologique
culturelle politique religieuse
un monde qui accueille la culture des
peuples ne toute la planète terre
leur position sur ce que doit signifier
la construction d'un nouveau monde d'une
nouvelle communauté humaine d'un monde
sans empire hégémonique d'un monde
libéré de la soif de domination
économique
financière militaire politique
libéré des tentatives d'hégémonie
[Musique]
de la part d'un empire ou de ceux qui
pendant des siècles et des siècles en
spoliés dominé exploiter opprimés les
peuples du monde grâce aux vieux
colonialisme cupides
ceux qui cherchent à imposer de
nouvelles formes de néocolonialisme à
notre peuple de nouvelles formes de
domination de spoliation d'oppression
d'exploitation des peuples du monde
voilà pourquoi lors de cette assemblée
générale touché par la pandémie est
depuis le coeur même de nos patries
[Musique]
qui nous sont si chers le venezuela
élève sa voix pour défendre un nouveau
monde sans colle hockey et colonialisme
pour un nouveau monde sans impérialisme
pour un nouveau monde sans hégémonie
pour un nouveau monde de partage de
coopération de communautés humaines au
destin commun un monde plus multipolaire
plus récente rick
auquel
nous aspirons
un monde qui nous amène à unir notre
étendard à celui de tous les peuples du
monde des peuples du sud pour défendre
particulièrement la doctrine du
mouvement des pays non-alignés la
doctrine sud sud notre doctrine notre
vision notre
engagement notre conviction
le venezuela a pu compter sur le soutien
décisif est majoritaire des pays du
monde
pour faire face aux circonstances
auxquelles nous notre pays a été
confronté au cours des dernières années
notre peuple
a indubitablement
su recevoir la solidarité le soutien la
coopération de dizaines de pays
ici représentés au sein de
l'organisation des nations unies dpi qui
ont pu entendre la voix de la vérité la
voix de notre peuple
le venezuela
a communiqué à l'assemblée générale des
sont unis à maintes reprises et à
communiquer
aux différents organismes du système des
nations unies
son message dénonçant l' attaque
féroce la campagne malveillante menées
contre notre pays menés par les élites
qui ont gouverné les états unis
une campagne
menée avec la complicité des élites qui
dirigent des organismes en europe et
ailleurs
l'on a cherché à instrumentaliser
les entités internationales
le droit international pour justifier
cette campagne malveillante et les
attaques criminelles perpétrées contre
un peuple noble pacifiques et
démocratiques tels que le peuple du
venezuela
à maintes reprises
nous avons
dénoncé ces faits devant les organismes
devant le siège de nombreux organismes
et aujourd'hui nous dénonçons à nouveau
ces faits devant l'assemblée générale
des nations unies à new york
à l'occasion
de l'assemblée générale annuelle en ce
mois de septembre 2021 le venezuela
dénonce une campagne
féroce dénonce une agression permanente
et systématique
dénonce les sanctions économiques
financières et pétrolières
des sanctions cruelles
dénonce les atteintes
au droit à la liberté économique
aux droits économiques et aux garanties
économiques dont devrait pouvoir jouir
tous les peuples du monde
une attaque
contre le droit d'acheter ce dont a
besoin notre pays contre le droit de
vendre ce que produit notre pays
notamment les grandes richesses
pétrolières et minières que possède le
venezuela et que le venezuela exploité
pendant des décennies
nos comptes bancaires sont pris pour
cible
lors des réserves internationales
légal de la banque centrale du venezuela
londres ont été confisqués bloquer
les milliards de dollars ont été
confisqués bloqués sur les comptes
bancaires aux états-unis en europe et
ailleurs les entreprises vénézuéliennes
dans le secteur
pétrolier et minier n'ont pas le droit
de commercialiser leurs produits n'ont
pas le droit d'ouvrir des comptes
bancaires dans le monde pour
payer en pc faire des transactions
commerciales librement tel que le
prévoit le droit international il s'agit
là d'une persécution financières
monétaires commerciales économiques
énergétiques
systématique cruel et criminel le
venezuela élève la voix pour les
dénoncer devant les peuples du monde
nous avons
fait l'objet de menaces pendant des
années des années de campagne
d'agression virulente
et je puis
vous le dire à vous aujourd'hui
depuis le coeur de caracas qui a vu
naître
l'émouvant libération d'amérique je puis
vous le dire le peuple vénézuélien
un peuple résilient un peuple résistant
le peuple vénézuélien s'est dressé en
2021 une année très particulière une
année merveilleuse qui coïncide avec
le 200e anniversaire de la victoire
définitive de la bataille de carabobo
bataille pour l'indépendance cette année
2021 nous à 2021 nous a permis de passer
d'une phase cruel douloureuse de
résistance à une phase de relèvement de
croissance soutenue fondée sur la
science l'innovation la technologie et
la capacité spirituel d'un peuple
travailleur qui refusent de courber
l'échiné
d'un peuple rebelle
libre
un peuple qui grandit qui a toujours
grandi
dans l'adversité de ces dernières années
nous avons emprunté le chemin
de la relance de la croissance
intégrale de notre nation nous avons
emprunté le chemin du déploiement des
forces productives d'un pays faisant
l'objet d'un blocus
infernal faisant l'objet de poursuites
criminelles de persécution faisant
l'objet d'une torture cruel envers son
corps économique et social nous
l'affirmons aux peuples du monde avec
courage détermination intelligence et
sagesse
il est possible
d'affronter ces agressions impérialistes
il est possible d'avancer voilà pourquoi
nous demandons nous exigeons que soit le
lever toutes les sanctions criminelles à
l'encontre de l'économie vénézuélienne à
l'encontre de la société vénézuélienne
imposées par les états unis d'amérique
imposées par les gouvernements de
l'union européenne
nous l'affirmons
au nom de 30 millions de vénézuéliens de
vénézuélienne nous remercions les pays
des nations unies
qui nous soutiennent dans la réalisation
de ce grand objectif pour notre pays
pour notre région je saisis cette
occasion pour
dire toute notre solidarité tout notre
soutien à la république de cuba au
peuple de cuba
qui
a exigé ce qui a été soutenu à 27
reprises par la majorité des membres des
nations unies que soit levé
immédiatement toutes les mesures de
blocus commercial et économique à
l'encontre de la république de cuba à
l'encontre du peuple de cuba le
venezuela élève la voix
au nom de la justice au nom de
l'humanité pour cuba une république un
peuple héroïque
notre pays
a su
surmonter tous ces obstacles
faire face à ces circonstances
il est par conséquent nécessaire
de faire connaître
au sein de l'assemblée générale annuelle
de faire connaître au secrétaire général
des nations unies à la présidence de
l'assemblée générale et à tous les
niveaux au sein des ambassades
représentant les gouvernements les
résultats officiels du rapport de la
rapporteure spéciale sur les sanctions
de l'organisation des nations unies qui
s'est rendue cette année au venezuela
pendant sept jours et qui a rédigé
un rapport
objectif
réaliste crues de ces sanctions
criminelles
ce rapport contient comme recommandation
la levée immédiate de ces sanctions
criminelles et le respect du droit
international et du droit international
humanitaire du respect du droit du
venezuela à la liberté
et à la garantie économique commerciale
financière
le droit du venezuela à l'exercice plein
et entier de ses droits en tant que pays
souverain membre de l'organisation des
nations unies
a aussi été l'année où nous avons pu
voir et nous nous en réjouissons comment
le venezuela avance sur deux voies
essentielles un dialogue inclusif en
faveur de la paix dans notre pays et la
tenue
de la 29e élections au cours des vingt
dernières années des élections de grande
ampleur qui se tiendront le 21 novembre
2000 21 afin d'élire toutes les
autorités régionales municipales et
locales
grâce au vote du peuple tel que le
stipule la constitution bolivarienne de
notre pays cette année nous avons créé
de nombreuses
tables rondes avec les entreprises
les secteurs sociaux le secteur privé
tous les secteurs politiques
nous avons choisi la voie du dialogue
mais surtout nous avons lancé un
dialogue national en faveur de la paix
de la souveraineté
dans la ville
de mexico
et ce tout récemment le 13 août c'est un
processus de dialogue capitale
l'objectif de ce dialogue de faire en
sorte les groupes d'opposition les plus
extrémistes qui avait cherché à
perpétrer un coup d'état au venezuela
qui avait soutenu une invasion étrangère
de notre territoire qui avait
cherché à m'assassiner
que ces groupes d'opposition extrémistes
dans l'enceinte politiques respectent la
constitution et reprennent la voie des
élections je puis l'affirmer devant les
nations unies nous y avons nous n'avons
réussi ne sommes pas parvenus à ce qu'il
revienne dans l'enceinte politique il
respecte la constitution et la voie des
urnes avec le soutien du gouvernement du
président andres manuel lopez obrador au
mexique avec l'aide
diplomatique du royaume de norvège grâce
à la présence directe du gouvernement de
la fédération de russie et du
gouvernement des pays bas
nous avons pu lancer
un programme global de relance sociale
économique
de relance de tout le venezuela grâce à
un dialogue je remercie le secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio
guterres est choix du soutien apporté au
processus de dialogue
du mexique et je demande aux nations
unies de soutenir le dialogue au mexique
pour que l'on puisse parvenir à de
nouveaux accords
partiels et que l'on puisse parvenir à
un accord global de renforcement de la
paix de la souveraineté de la prospérité
et de la relance et du relèvement de
tout le venezuela c'est ce que je vous
demande et je vous en remercie
le venezuela
continuera de participer à toutes les
enceintes internationales
dans les entités chargées de la lutte
contre le changement climatique nous
avons dit qu'il était urgent
de riposter
de façon concrète
et vérifiable à l'impact des gaz à effet
de serre à l'impact du réchauffement des
mers
du réchauffement de la planète à
l'impact de tous les phénomènes
et catastrophes provoquées par les
changements climatiques
nous avons besoin
d'agir de mesures vérifiables et
efficace pour ralentir l'accélération de
la détérioration de l'équilibré
écologique de la planète terre
nous avons vu ce qui s'est passé au
cours des dernières années nous l'avons
vu
ici même dans la ville siège des nations
unies à new york que nous avons vues ces
inondations de grande ampleur nous avons
vu ces incendies les inondations qui ont
fait des ravages en inde en chine à new
york en espagne au venezuela nous avons
vu ces grandes sécheresses au sud de
l'amérique du sud
nous avons vu la sécheresse totale du
fleuve parana ne jamais vu
nous n'avons d'autre choix que d'exiger
des gouvernements
pouvant le faire qu'ils agissent de
façon efficace efficient pour réduire le
réchauffement global pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et pour
donner espoir au monde
face à une situation
profondément préoccupante tragique pour
de nombreux citoyens sur la planète
terre
le système des nations unies
et
l'enceinte même du monde multilatéral du
droit international ce sont là des
espaces à renforcer
c'est l'espace de la souveraineté des
peuples du monde
une souveraineté qui s'exerce dans le
respect du droit international
il nous faut bâtir un nouveau monde un
monde né de l'afrique n'est de l'asie
n'est de l'amérique latine et des
caraïbes n'est des peuples des états
unis d'amérique du nord c'est un nouveau
monde qui renaît
pour reléguer aux oubliettes les
hégémonies d'hier pour reléguer aux
oubliettes
la volonté de certains
d'être juge et partie de tous les
peuples du monde
l'heure est venue pour la liberté la
souveraineté l'indépendance un nouveau
monde passera par une nouvelle
organisation des nations unies une
nouvelle onu dans un nouveau monde pour
que nous puissions tous
partagé la vie pour que nous puissions
tous partage et la solidarité
pour que nous puissions avancer sur le
chemin juste et nécessaire d'une
nouvelle communauté dans un monde
nouveau
le venezuela élève la voix pour défendre
ce nouveau monde merci très chers
gouvernants du monde merci à tous les
peuples à toutes les autorités de
l'organisation des nations unies
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
au nom de l'assemblée générale je tiens
à remercier le président la république
bolivarienne du venezuela de
l'allocution qu'il vient de prononcer
l'assemblée
va entendre l'allocution de son
excellence monsieur
aulas écoulerait lso
président de la mongolie je puis le
protocole et bien vouloir accompagner
son excellence